he's going to throw again here steps up
Hees it deep downfield he's got Chris
Hilton and he's got a
[Applause]
touchdown that's what he does to the end
zone for Lacy got it
touchdown here's Daniels on fourth down
going to launch it to the end zone
neighbors holds it in
again but he can't wear number seven cuz
he's an offensive tackle so he's wearing
the patch Daniels downfield and right
into the arms
of Daniels against the fourman rush
throws downfield looking for Thomas
again he's got it and LSU strikes back
it's time a fourman rush quarterback run
right up the middle goes Jaden Daniels
he's got the first down and more Daniels
hunting the Pyon down the sideline into
the
redone Daniels he's going to take a shot
Kiren Lacy
he's got it that's an LSU touchdown he's
showing you his skills on full display
tonight this might be a free play Jaden
Daniels he's going to take a shot why
not it was a neutral zone infraction the
catch
[Applause]
made Daniels looking downfield he wants
a shot for Bryant Thomas into the end
zone
touchdown quarterback draw the Seas part
there goes Daniels again he's looking
for the end zone
touchdown they'll try and run for it
with Diggs or rather Daniels hopping
over tacklers and there he goes
again Jaden
Daniels wonder if us Weekly's watching
this one tonight here's Jaden Daniels on
the run and going down the sideline
caught by bran Thomas Jr and he will
take it to the house 86 yd LSU second
down and five from the 22 Jaden
Daniels going to try to scramble out of
trouble and he got away from everybody
and here he goes Daniel's second long
run of the
night Daniel's going to take off on his
own he's going to get the first down and
he's still going Daniels can they track
him down finally they do wow what a run
again Malik neighbors a motion man for
the Tigers settles in a slot on the
right side and Daniel
setting for the throw but now he'll
settle for the Run oh and look at that
move and then he gets hammered from
behind by Dallas Turner who member of
their secondary quarterback dein Moore
is unavailable tonight
Daniels now starts the run runs right
past one splits two more gets the
sideline Jaden Daniels is something
special Caleb Jackson is his running
back and Daniels pulls it takes it
himself he's got the sideline Jaden
Daniels Off to the Races and a Bend back
inside he takes it to the house 85 yds
for
Daniels Florida drops into a Zone
Daniels trying to run it got some space
what a move Jaden Daniels again Jaden
Daniels touchdown
LSU 51 y second and two Daniels going
deep looking for touch he's got Thomas
down to the
10 Blitz again Daniel Stands Tall going
deep in zone touchdown Bryan Thomas
J Mike Den Brock calling plays they've
been riding a bit of a heater pressure
Daniels escapes again there he goes
Daniels into the open
field
slippery can't wait for it Kevin Connor
Thank You Back To Live Action Thomas
breaking open holds it in Thomas tripped
up fourth in the state in 100 meters
play action Daniels Hees one long and it
is caught for the
touchdown ason Taylor was in
motion Daniels out of the pocket he's
going to run for it and get it and then
so Daniels Down the
sideline finally out of bounds inside
the 10 yd
line very very
good Jaden Daniels looking for the End
[Applause]
Zone another Blitz one-on-one for
Neighbors he's got
it touchdown oh my goodness by Malik
neighbors Daniels oneon-one pant
Lacy touch
down